[Music]
if you were going to date anybody else
from bachelor nation would that be a
possibility anybody here into from other
seasons from Knicks season you know I
don't know I I'd like to meet some of
them I think some of them really cool
but just watching it's so hard to really
learn like I don't know I guess I'm
maybe a little jaded to a certain extent
but it's hard to learn I think there's
so much more you need to learn to meet
these girls in person yeah would you go
in paradise if given the chance I've
already been asked and I don't know what
to do even ask for this season
the both seasons I was asked last season
I said no but now you're reconsidering I
don't know just what do you think I
should do well I want you to do it you
know I've gotten chubby my concern is
like those guys have abs the one thing
that a lot of people don't get to see is
my like kind of hokey side so I would
probably I know I would have a ton of
fun but I don't know if I can keep my
t-shirt on when I'm in the ocean
[Music]